So for quite a long time,
people built portfolios this way.
They would look at a bunch of assets,
essentially equally weight them,
and end up with a portfolio that
behaved somewhat in between.
Now, if you wanted a low-risk portfolio,
you should focus on assets
that are low risk out here.
If you wanted, for
instance, high return,
you should focus on assets over here.
In both those cases you would end
up with a portfolio, say, here, or
a portfolio, say, here.
Now, can we do better?
In other words, is it possible
to get portfolios over here?
So can we have a portfolio here
that has a return similar to
these assets over here, but
risk similar to these assets over here?
Indeed we can, and
it's due to a man named Harry Markowitz,
who won the Nobel Prize for his insight.
What he discovered, and
what people had been overlooking,
was the relationship between
stocks in terms of covariance.
So the resulting
performance of a portfolio,
especially in terms of risk,
is not just a factor, or
a blend of the various risks, but it has
to do with how they interact day to day.
So indeed, if we pick the right
stocks in the right proportions,
we can get a portfolio that
performs over here, that in fact,
can have lower risk than any
of the individual assets,
and I'll show you how to
do that in just a moment.
Now before I do that,
I want to mention though one other
thing about Harry Markowitz.
Up until the time of his discovery,
most people viewed bonds
as the lowest risk asset,
in other words, if you wanted low risk,
you should use bonds orly.
Markowitz showed that
a blend of stocks and
bonds is actually lower risk than
either one of those by themselves.
And I'll show you how that
makes sense in a moment.